cinq millions de français tous les ans
et des milliers d' yves launoy la 31e
édition du téléthon sera une nouvelle
fois un rendez vous important pour la
solidarité et la recherche contre les
maladies rares à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de nombreux
acteurs locaux sont mobilisés c'est le
cas des chocs ce d'elancourt qui
organiseront dimanche leur
traditionnelle est disco roller entre 14
et 18 heures traditionnel aussi les
animations prévues vendredi et samedi au
centre sportif les pyramides de
voisins-le-bretonneux ou encore les 25
heures d'activités non stop organisé par
l'association objectif téléthon manie
quoi elle l'édition 2016 avait permis de
récolter près de 700000 euros sur les
yvelines un gain est essentielle pour
soutenir la recherche en avance avance
tous les ans là mais il ya encore
beaucoup à faire sur relève les
problèmes de vue sur les problèmes
des muscles tout ça en un respiratoires
aussi en a encore beaucoup à faire au
niveau de la recherche
malheureusement le tunnel est encore
lent la manifestation historique aussi
sur saint quentin en yvelines les trois
jours d'événements au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin dès vendredi soir à
montigny le bretonneux où les 30 heures
d'animations aux clayes-sous-bois avec
un fest noz samedi soir pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer il est toujours
possible de faire un don par téléphone
ou sur internet l'an dernier 80 millions
d'euros ont été récoltés partout en
france lors du téléthon